[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
je vais vous raconter l'histoire d'enzo
enzo
comme beaucoup d'enfants de son âge va
entrer en maternelle en septembre
prochain
ce qu'il ne sait pas encore c'est qui va
se confronter un mâle immense et
invisible ce mal c'est le conformisme le
conformiste commencent à se manifester
dès la maternelle on commence à avoir
des évaluations même si c'est encore des
notes on commence à prendre un langage
pas n'importe quel langage un langage
particulier et de manière générale ses
débuts de la pression sociale pressions
de groupes à l'école enzo apprendre à
lire à pompe et à réfléchir
mais il va aussi comprendre que pour
avoir un sésame d'une évaluation
positive
il va falloir se conformer au système le
collège dont kenzo à shenzhen d'année se
confirme va décoller l eau va commencer
à apprendre les mécanismes des
dissertations qui est à part est égale
pour tous et le collège d'ailleurs sous
couvert d'égalité va sélectionner le
lycée maintenant c'est l'avènement c'est
l'aboutissement de cette logique le
temple du conformisme avec son rythme
non non conformiste du bac le bac qui
pour ceux sans doute qu'ils ont passé et
plus une épreuve où le but est de
replacer le plus de connaissances
possible un moment donné est pas tant le
reflet d'un vrai apprentissage en dopant
fait ce qu'on voit c'est que à chaque à
chaque étape on retrouve le conformisme
et tout ce système marche un peu sur
injonction
marche ou crève soit
enzo va se conformer dans ce cas là il a
des bons résultats
il a les orientations qui veut il
parvient dans de bonnes filières et je
ne jette pas très repères parce que moi
même si je suis là par les banques
aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai su en
bénéficier de ce conformisme
mais si l d'eau par contre a du mal
s'il ya des lacunes s'il ne comprend pas
ce qu'on attend de lui ici à nîmes à la
plaque et ses connaissances sur le
papier
las les difficultés commencent parce que
l on va peut être redoublés enzo va
peut-être étreinte et faire une filière
contre son gré et peut-être que enzo va
même être en échec scolaire et décrocher
et quand on voit ce que ce qu'on dit
actuellement de l'école on voit que des
cas comme enzo d enzo en difficulté il y
en a beaucoup
il est de notoriété commune que l'école
française est sélective inégalitaire et
incapable de répondre à l'échec scolaire
alors ces primes de date
évidemment pas d'hier et certains vont
demander le recours le retour bardon à
l'école des années 50 des années 60
voire pour les plus audacieux à l'école
de la troisième république et ils vont
arguer que à l'époque le maître était
tout puissant
l'élève obéissant et que l'échec
n'existait pas vous vous en doutez c'est
faux
cette école est un mythe cette école est
un fantasme elle n'a sans doute jamais
existé et ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
n'existera jamais ce qu'il nous faut
aujourd'hui c'est une rupture radicale
avec le conformisme une véritable
révolution éducative
vous allez me dire oui mais une large
part des difficultés ne sont pas
expliqués par le conformisme et vous
avez raison il ya bien sûr la faiblesse
des moyens
il ya bien sûr le problème des
inégalités mais la question du
conformisme et trop souvent occulté ce
moment et quand on entend l'opinion
publique qui blâment souvent la
passivité des jeunes leur manque
d'initiative et que de l'autre côté on
voit ces jeunes qui répondent en d'une
certaine manière en rêvant de quitter la
france et je sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler mais il ya quelques mois
il y avait l'histoire de cette étudiante
qui a écrit à françois hollande
les raisons de son expatriation quand on
voit cela on comprend
moi personnellement en tout cas je
comprends ces personnes de mon âge qui
ont du mal à se retrouver dans ce
système d'un système éducatif qui est
pas tendre qui a été très exigeant peut
être trop exigeant qui fixe la barre
très haute en terme de connaissances en
termes de compétences et qui au final
laisse peu de place pour la créativité
où la personnalité
je ne cherche pas toutefois à noircir le
tableau
je ne cherche pas un cerveau tableau
depuis l'après-guerre avec tout ce qu'on
connaît la démocratisation la
massification selon les points de vue et
surtout depuis ces trente dernières
années des réformes ont été faites pour
mettre l'élève un peu plus au centre du
système que ça soit par la mise en place
d' accompagner d'accompagnement
personnalisé au collège et au lycée par
l'épreuve de travaux personnels encadrés
au baccalauréat qui force les élèves à
réfléchir en groupe ou encore même par
la présence au baccalauréat d'épreuves
artistique est optionnel qui vise un peu
à mettre de l'évaluation extrascolaires
aussi dans le baccalauréat et même la
dernière réforme du collège
quoi qu'on en pense va également dans ce
sens là mais ces réformes sont sans
doute insuffisante au regard des enjeux
auxquels il faut répondre avant l'école
doit être publique école l'après guerre
devait former des citoyens et des
travailleurs aguerris qui serait
obéissant quand il le fallait et discret
reste du temps le conformisme n'était
pas un problème parce que l'école se
devait être homogénéisant tu es
aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec la crise du
système scolaire avec les nouveaux
enjeux qu'ils soient écologiques
politiques sociaux sociétaux
les enjeux sont autres et qui dit enjeu
autre dit nouveau système d'où l'intérêt
d'une réforme radicale mais attention
cette réforme radicale ne signifie pas
rupture et abandon total du système
actuel le système français même si on
peut le critiquer reste à bien des
égards préférable à d'autres
alternatives est un exemple en est la
dissertation
parce que d'un côté la dissertation
c'est un outil éminemment républicain
un outil qui force les élèves à prendre
position à réfléchir sur un sujet et à
confronter les différentes positions
dessus mais c'est aussi un outil qui
peut être stigmatisant
parce que la difficulté de la vie la
difficulté de la dissertation n'est pas
de la même pour tous certains vont
assimilé le mécanisme très vite d'autres
ont beaucoup plus de mal et il ya un
énorme problème de méthodologie d'un
système français parce qu on part du
principe que tout le monde est égal face
à cette difficulté mais ce n'est pas le
cas tout le monde ne possède pas les
codes de la dissertation et si on ne
possède pas les codes on ne peut pas
jouer le jeu on peut pas adopter de
position critiques ou d'avoir de
réflexion c'est pourquoi et la
dissertation d'ailleurs comme n'importe
quel exercice ne peut pas se résumer à
seulement emmagasiner des connaissances
peut-être que cela passe par un peu
moins d'apprentissage mais un
apprentissage de meilleure qualité et le
but de tout cela c'est organiser la
réflexion lancé la réflexion d'un essai
organiser le débat où les élèves
pourraient mêmes devraient donner leur
opinion à partir de leurs connaissances
mais aussi et surtout à partir de leur
propre opinion
l'école ne peut pas se résumer à la
seule évaluation et l'évaluation
d'ailleurs dont je n'aime pas en cause
d'intérêts doit aussi être vue doit être
revu pour être plus positif se fonder
sur vraiment les connaissances acquises
et non la conformité système la note ne
doit pas être une finalité elle doit
rester un moyen et la moyenne ce fameux
10 sur 20 ne doit pas être un couperet
vous connaissez sans doute le phénomène
de constante macabre qui est désigne un
pourcentage constant de mauvaises notes
peu importe le devoir peu importe
professeur peu importe à classe ce
phénomène décrit en fait la déconnexion
entre notes et savoir et le problème
avec l'addiction des connexions entre
notes et savoir c'est que l'évaluation
je fais plus sur des sur des quelque
chose d'objectif mais se fait sur la
conformité au système et donc lutter
contre le conformisme c'est aussi
accepter et anticiper les difficultés à
l'école c'est remettre en cause l'idée
al damiri frère unique et d'un archétype
de bons élèves auxquels il faudrait
absolument se conformer c'est accepter
que le mérite et plurielle et que chacun
un potentiel et c'est dire ça ce n'est
pas remettre en cause la qualité d'un
système où la qualité des diplômes
données
c'est seulement accepter le fait qu'on
ne peut pas former un élève
excellent au prix de l'abandon de neuf
autres élèves plus faibles dire cela ce
n'est pas c'est accepter que chacun
potentiel et que l'école n'a pas à
formater ce potentiel
alors certains disent aussi très présent
dans le débat public que l'école n'est
pas assez adapté à la vie
professionnelle aux exigences
d'entreprise que les savoirs acquis sont
trop abstrait mais je pense que c'est
plutôt au contraire au contraire l'école
n'est plus temps un lieu de formation
d'apprentissage mais devenu une plutôt
une institution où on doit appliquer
savoir et ça c'est c'est un problème et
l'école ne peut pas nous va se résumer à
un apprentissage des intéressés le
conformisme il balaye toute notion
d'apprentissage intéressés il se résume
en fait un mécanisme simple ingurgité et
régurgiter connaissance et l école et je
pense peut aller plus loin de là un
exemple en n peut-être certains d'entre
eux connaissent la devise la devise est
un spectacle monté par le théâtre dijon
bourgogne ya quelques mois et qui a été
joué dans les lycées et comme son nom
l'indiqué le but était de faire
réfléchir sur le sens traduite française
ce qui a impliqué aujourd'hui et surtout
faire débattre les élèves dessus après
la pièce et ça marche et ça a marché
parce que justement pour une fois on
demandait aux élèves ce qu'ils pensaient
pas seulement d'appliquer et d'accepter
mécaniquement la devise liberté égalité
fraternité mais également à réfléchir
sur le sens et ça je pense vraiment que
c'est possible à l'échelle de toutes les
écoles et de toute la france
c'est possible et même nécessaire pour
que les élèves puissent avoir un recul
sur ce qu'ils apprennent puisse avoir
une pluie une position critique afin que
eux-mêmes puisse dépasser leurs propres
préjugés et également mettre fin à
l'auto exclusion et l'auto
disqualification qui pousse certains à
l'échec
il faut casser ces mentalités
il faut rejeter le conformisme pour
créer une nouvelle école une école où la
mixité sociale serait assuré une école
où les établissements seraient cogérée
par les élèves et le personnel
une école où les classes seraient
peut-être plus petit mais aux élèves
pour mieux accompagner et une école où
la note ne serait pas déterminant de
tous le rejet du conformisme n'est
qu'une première étape dans ce long
chemin vers l'école du 21e siècle
une école qui n'attendraient pas
asservir sud mais le libre arbitre
une école qui formerait des citoyens
engagés et politisé et pas des citoyens
passifs nous méritons mieux qu'une école
eugéniste une école qui aurait pu très
bien imaginer à lui succède en mer des
mondes le conformisme c'est pas
l'apanage du totalitarisme
il existe dans nos démocraties et
constituait un grand péril c'est pour ça
que nous devons chasser le conformisme
notre école est le 21e siècle sera le
siècle de l'école anticonformiste ou ne
sera pas merci
[Applaudissements]